joining us here on the rich eisen show
prior to the game that you could see on
nbc and peacock on sunday night between
the steelers and the chiefs is the
freshly minted
first team all pro cam hayward how are
you doing cam
i'm good and yourself i am doing well
congrats on the first team all pro man
congrats thank you thank you i
appreciate it who told you because this
came out i think about 10 minutes ago
uh you just told me are you serious yes
sir
hey
yeah appreciate it no kidding yeah that
just congratulations that literally wow
i'm like the paul revere here
the all-pro is coming
yeah man uh it's it's you you want to
guess who the other uh
the other
defensive
interior lineman is
that's all pro
that's correct that's correct
yes sir
it's you and him and you want to guess
who the edge rushers are on the line
with you um hmm let me guess i'm gonna
say tj and miles garrett that is correct
you sure you didn't see this cameron
come on oh i haven't seen that yes
indeed those guys have had the best
seasons what do you expect
well i mean sometimes you put something
in the old voting booth and you never
know what's going to be spit out you
know what i mean but um
what is very true so this is literally
first blush what does it mean to be
named as such cam hayward um
man it's a big honor um i put a lot of
work in this off season
um you know to be
viewed as one of the top d-linemen in
our league
you know i'm just very lucky uh i know
it's not a guarantee and i got to put in
the work but uh you know very honored to
be known as an all-pro this year and
then uh i question i know the answer to
i guess already but i'll ask anyway
what does it mean to be named on that
line with your teammate t.j watt cameron
hayward man
man you you there's not a more deserving
guy
of being all pro
hopefully defensive player of the year
um you know leading the leading stacks
again
but uh you know as a group we're leading
the league um
and i'm sure he'll tell you we've got a
bunch of guys that make this thing
possible but that dude is
part of the locomotive and you know he
keeps us all together and you also had a
front row seat to him
fighting through injuries too i would
imagine yeah right yeah plenty plenty of
injuries but you know when we get him
out there and he's playing most of the
plays um you know there's not a lot of
guys that can beat him um we're very
lucky to have a guy that when he steps
on the field he's going to give you a
chance and you also had a front row seat
did he get hosed out of the sack record
last week yeah
yeah well two things one yeah my dumb
penalty caused him
uh to not get the one sack
um
they called me for roughing the passer
uh when the guy's running the ball
uh figures and then the next one
um
you know it was a botched fumble he
picks it the quarterback picks it back
up and tries to get up tj sat you know
to me he sacks him and makes him fumble
um but it gets viewed as a aborted play
which is you know a load of crap to me
yeah man uh i was talking about it with
his brother jj yesterday you know and so
um
nonetheless i mean you're all pros and
congratulations on that cameron hayward
here on the rich eisen show
how long of a day was sunday walk me
through sunday
for you
um
you know you know trying to stay focused
on our game uh but you're seeing the
you know jacksonville and colts game uh
colts
were struggling and jacksonville put it
away and you know baltimore is excited
because if they're feeling like they got
a chance
we go to overtime
um
and you know it was it was a grinded out
type of game um you know and we were
able to get get the ball one last time
uh you know score a field goal with two
minutes left in overtime
um and we're feeling pretty good
and then you start watching the uh
the
chargers and raiders game coming on at
eight o'clock and
man my night went
very long into the night
you know my kids were woken up by me
what do you mean
what do you mean it was a little loud a
little loud you know about what like
what what in particular got you loud
cameron hayward of watching the amount
of fourth downs they converted
dude you guys can end it right here and
oh every time you know justin herbert
you know came up with big plays and i'm
like come on
um but you know i i really you really
got to thank josh jacobs because i feel
like he he put us in range to
you know for them to get a field goal
and i'm like thank god and you know they
kicked the field goal went through i was
like all right we got a shot now so
you know that was about at like 1 30 in
the morning
yeah it was a long night you know i'll
tell you just as a fan and um watching
it and understanding what the the stakes
are and what have you
um it was exhilarating right and and and
just watching that and just i was on the
edge of my seat the number of people
have called into the show or friends of
mine who we've been talking and texting
saying that that was one of the most
incredible
games of football and weeks of football
and sunday games of football but you
this is your livelihood man we just
talked about your all pro season and the
amount of work you put in in the off
season and what you were doing this
season and how
you know the tie against the lions kind
of set all of these things in motion
because if there was a three-way tie at
nine seven and one you were out and
and and yeah and it's all hanging in the
balance like that
that that must have driven you nuts you
know sitting there watching it did
you know and like
chris collinsworth uh was killing me
with you know his talk about the tie
during the game i'm like
no way this ends in a freaking time you
kept bringing it up i'm like
bro like stop you're killing me
um
and you know
you never want to have your fate in
somebody else's hand
but we did and
now we just got to make the most out of
this um and letting up not let it be in
vain yeah and before we get to that
though do you think the chargers timeout
that they took because brandon staley
said he wanted to get the proper run
defense on the field and interestingly
enough
josh jacobs ran through that run defense
for a first down do you think that that
time out did in fact help you and the
pittsburgh steelers make the playoffs
because that led to the field goal do
you think that made a difference knowing
football as you do
you know
he would the football person he says
yeah it helps
but the competitor in me is like you
know maybe they really wanted to win the
game but
um
you know i i just it was
oh i'm glad it ended up the way it did
right
cameron hayward of the pittsburgh
steelers here on the rich eisen show
let's jump into it then um
ben even mentioned this week you know uh
that nobody's giving you a chance
do you feel that way right now
yeah you know um
you know rightfully so you know they've
got a
uh
um
hall of fame quarterback and homes and
you know
skill
pieces galore um opportunistic defense
um
you know they uh finished number two in
the afc
not a lot of people are giving us a
chance um but you know to my guys in my
locker room um the 53 men and the staff
and the organization and our practice
squad we bel we believe in ourselves
um and you know we'll see what happens
okay uh what do you think needs to do to
make it happen for you in the way that
you want aka a win
what do you need you know i think we got
it we got to get off on third downs um
you know i think last time they were
sustaining a a big drive that was like
10 minutes long
um you know
we got to be ready for you know the
the
i wouldn't say scrambles but the
prolonged plays that patrick does that
extends the plays and you know breaks
coverage uh because our db shouldn't be
having to cover for 10 to 12 seconds and
when he does that he usually makes
somebody pay um
and you know our offenses got put up
some points you know you're playing the
hot line team um but
we we feel like we got some really good
players on offense as well and then uh
what was it like obviously you know
you're born in pittsburgh your your dad
we all understand
um the history um for you and your
family in pittsburgh what was that
moment like in pittsburgh when ben
and you won that game in what was being
billed as
the last game for roethlisberger in
heinz field what was that one like man i
you know not a lot of players get send
offs
um
and i know
steeler nation has loved
ben since he's been here brought home
super bowls
um and you know
what a fitting way against arrival
in cleveland browns
to you know get that win for him um you
know a lot of players on our team just
thought let's just play you know how we
apprec how we want to appreciate ben
you know show him how much we've we care
about him and what he's done for us
let's go out there and win this game
and um and is there a sense of not
wanting maybe the career to end right
now is there because again uh you know
the game is not a super bowl's not
winding up in ben's hometown like bettis
did years ago but there's kind of like
that sense that you could go on that
mission similar to a steelers
championship season of 2005. is there a
sense of like that
you know i think
first of all there's no championships in
uh findlay ohio coming anytime soon i'm
sorry finley ohio i would love for it
but i don't know if you guys could
accomplish it accommodate a super bowl
anytime soon yes um
might be a few rooms shortly you know i
think
i think uh you know
we all
understand the magnitude
of the single game elimination um not
only will end our our season but
it could be the end of you know one of
the greatest um you know super bowl
warning quarterbacks
uh in our generation and we've been
lucky enough to call my teammate and
i don't think we're ready to let that
party in you know what better way to
have a retirement party than ride this
thing out to the super bowl okay man i
love it and i appreciate you calling in
and and the times that we've we've
gotten a chance uh certainly this season
to talk but i am mandated to
finish up with this speaking of a hotel
room in ohio it does appear that you
were in one in the last saturday of
november um
cameron uh watching i imagine a certain
football game on television
that was taking place in the state of
michigan
um
any thoughts on the subject matter at
all
of the contents of michigan uh putting a
40 burger on the ohio state
this year yeah
that that
as much as it kills me as an ohio state
guy it even kills me more as a
defensive guy okay um
we're not accommodating to that and
um
you you got you guys got us okay we'll
leave it at that and we'll see you guys
next year okay um
i'll see you soon okay is it a problem
if we don't leave it at that for there's
a split moment um
because you know i was very pleased
cameron at least for you that uh the
basketball team beat duke two days later
and now ohio state is a basketball
school your thoughts on that subject
matter
cameron we're not a basketball school
we've had some really good players this
is good uh but at the end of the day we
are a football school we are not the
unc's
um okay
all right all right just throwing that
out there what do you think of aiden
hutchinson what do you think of him
seeing him play as just a
pass rusher here
pressure you know i love his motor um
you know and i know they need him in
some critical games um you know my
brother got to play against someone you
know my brother plays in michigan yeah
so i know i know yeah yeah yeah
but uh
so much fun
oh gosh uh cameron hayward uh congrats
again i'm kind of i'm honored that i got
to tell you that you made the first team
all pro let's make this a regular thing
let's do that let's do that i appreciate
it
we'll get drinks and everything i'd love
it i look forward to that um maybe i'll
see you here in los angeles in a few
weeks you never know maybe right
see you later okay
take care cameron hayward thanks for the
time
guys you got it there you go that's uh
cam thanks again all pro
oh that's an all-pro
getting ready
for a playoff game
kansas
city ladies and gentlemen
steelers at chiefs
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here